what exactly is
truth
is it possible to know I think Spinoza
is right about truth that truth is only
known by its own standard which sounds
circular there's a way in which he
didn't mean that circularly and I think
this is also converges with Plato these
are two huge influences on me
I think we only know the truth
retrospectively when we when we go
through some process of
self-transcendence when we move from a
frame to a more encompassing frame so
that we can see the limitations and the
distortions of the earlier frame you
have this when you have a moment of
insight Insight is you doing you're you
are re-realizing what is relevant
you go oh oh
I thought she was aggressive
and angry she's actually really afraid
I was misframing this
right and you CH you change what you
find relevant you have those aha moments
so do you think it's possible
to get a a sense of objective reality
so
is it possible to have to get to the
ground level of what something that you
can call objective truth
or is it are we always on Shaky Ground
I think those moments of transcendence
can never get us to an absolute view
from nowhere
all right and so this is Drew Hyland's
notion of finite Transcendence we are
capable of self-transcendence and
therefore we are creatures who can
actually raise the question of Truth or
goodness or beauty because I think
they're they all share this feature
but that doesn't mean we can transcend
to a godhood to some absolute uh view
from nowhere that takes in all
information
and organizes it in a comprehensive
whole but that doesn't mean that truth
is thereby rendered valueless
um
I I I think a better term is real
and real and illusory are comparative
terms you only know that something's an
illusion
by taking something else to be real
and so we're always in a comparative
task but that doesn't mean that we can
we can somehow jump outside of our
framing in some final Manner and say
this is how it is from a God's eye point
of view so what do you think if I may
ask
uh of somebody like iron Rand and her
philosophy of objectivism
so we're the core principles that
reality exists independently of
Consciousness and that human beings have
direct contact with reality through
sense perception so they have that you
do have that ability to know reality
there's two things knowing that there's
an independent reality is not knowing in
that independent reality those are not
the same thing yeah but I think
objectivism would probably
say that our human reason is able to
have contact with that then I would
respond and say
you have to I believe in fact ultimately
in a Conformity theory of knowing that
what that the deepest kind of knowing is
when
there's a a contact a Conformity between
the mind with the embodied mind and
reality but and here's where I guess I'd
push back on on Rand I would say you
have to acknowledge personal knowledge
as real knowledge because if you don't
you're going to fall prey at amino's
paradox
amino's Paradox is you know this is in
Plato right
to no P well
if I don't know P I'm going to go
looking for it but if I don't know P how
could I possibly recognize it when I
found it
I have no way of recognize it I know I
have no way of knowing that I've found
it
so I must know P but if I know P then I
don't need to learn about it I don't
need to go searching
so learning doesn't exist knowledge is
impossible
the way you break out of that Paradox is
saying no no no it is partial it is
possible to partially know something I
can know it enough that it will guide me
to recognizing it but that's not the
same as having a complete grasp of it
because I still have to search and find
what I don't yet possess in my knowledge
if we so yeah partial knowledge has to
be real knowledge right personal
knowledge is still knowledge yes